what's going on people today we're
theorizing how attack on titan would
have gone in a completely different
direction if erin was the one chosen to
inherit the colossal in case you're new
to the channel i'm going to start this
video off by doing a quick recap of this
whole alternate timeline so far but if
you want even more details then i just
recommend watching the first four parts
of this series
okay so back in part one levi made the
decision to inject air in with the
transformation serum enabling him to eat
bertolt and become the new colossal
titan following that the commander
fulfilled his lifelong dream of learning
the truth about the outside world and
alongside everyone else he realizes that
their true enemy is the most powerful
nation on the planet knowing that marley
would eventually return for the founding
titan irvin spent months rebuilding the
survey call with the intention of making
them into an army they could fight
against humans as well as titans in the
year 851 yelena and yankpon then arrive
on the island and thanks to certain
information that they reveal the
commander would see a chance to take
down mali by forming an alliance with
hizru in the middle east in order to
make this a reality though he'd first
need to take a gamble and work with the
volunteers which is risky considering
their close relationship to the beast
titan the following year ambassador
kyomi then takes a trip to shiganshina
where irving convinces her to go behind
zeke's back to form a new agreement with
him in this new deal parodies agrees to
give her access to a chunk of their
natural resources in exchange for his
providing technology and assistance in
his plan to beat the malians moving on
to part two this one begins a couple
years later in the year 854 at a time
when mali was still at war with the
middle east despite the ongoing conflict
the four warriors were temporarily
recalled back to liberia after willie
tiber received credible evidence that
shifters from parodies had infiltrated
the continent with peak zeke reiner and
porco all being back home this gave the
middle eastern forces a massive boost
and more importantly it laid the
foundation for ervin's plan to dismantle
the warriors on one particular night
zeke invites his comrades and their
families around for dinner where he
offers them a suspect amount of wine and
as everyone makes their way home this is
basically when the new war begins during
the rest of the video aaron confronts
reiner in his home before blowing the
place up irving wipes out virtually all
of molly's highest ranking officers and
zeke betrays pete by trapping her
underground part two then comes to an
end with reiner and pogo being captured
by the scouts while flock is transformed
into a pure titan so that he can become
the next armoured however before it can
happen the warhammer makes a surprise
interruption as it turns out willie had
secretly sent her to liberio in case she
was needed in the fight against the
colossal this brings us to part three
which was by far the longest video in
the series and in this one both sides
took massive losses for a start reiner's
mother was confirmed to have been
crushed by aaron while pique's dad and
pogo's parents were turned into pure
titans by zeke the beast titan then uses
them to defend himself from the
warhammer as mikasa repeatedly attacks
it with thunderspears at the same time
on another side of liberio pete manages
to escape from our underground prison
but in the process kills han ji nal and
a few other scouts her magathen link up
and run towards the sound of the scream
but by the time they get there the
warriors have already been defeated with
flock eating the armored aaron eating
the warhammer and louise being selected
to eat the draw titan peak then watches
on as jean blows up hadas pure titan and
a second later airships arrived from his
route to collect the survey corps over
the next 12 hours the scouts then split
into different teams and with the help
of hezru's army they destroyed tons of
malian bases including fort salter
unfortunately though jean gets ambushed
by the cart titan and following a brutal
interrogation peak and mcgath learned
that zeke's royal blood is the key to
unlocking the founder after executing
jean they then bring this intel to a
grieving willie tiber who understandably
wants revenge for the death of his
sister the three of them then come up
with an intricate plan to strike back
against the scouts although for this
plan to work they decide that mali first
needs to surrender to the enemy as you
can imagine this surrender has major
political ramifications all across the
world and over the next 7 months a ton
of things happened that were explained
in the part 3 video itself for the
purpose of this recap though there are
just three main things we need to
mention with the first being that evan
betrays zeke and has him locked up miles
away from the walls thing number two is
the hitch is selected by the mps to
inherit the female titan and finally
number three is that willy uses his
political influence to form an alliance
between nations who were afraid of the
new alden empire in part 4 this global
alliance then launches a surprise attack
on the island with pete confronting the
beast titan and eventually eating him as
revenge for liberia it should be
mentioned that flock levi and irvin
tried their best to stop this from
happening but by the time they arrived
at the prison it was already too late
simultaneously in shiganshina hundreds
of pure titans were dropped into the
district forcing aaron to reveal himself
as he tries to protect the population me
concerned the other scouts then joined
the fight as well and after briefly
hesitating hitch also decides to help
out the attack titan sadly for her
though mcgath was perched on top of
wilmaria inside an anti-tyne cannon and
as part of his mission he's allowed to
kill any shifter except the founder for
that reason he strategically shoots the
attack titan's brain to prevent aaron
from moving and this is followed up by
him blowing out hitch's nape by aiming
for this specific area he instantly
crushes her human body and this was all
witnessed by historia and louise who
were inside a nearby fortress part 4
then comes to an end with an exhausted
urban about to be eaten by the new and
improved beast titan but just as she's
about to deal the finishing blow the
commander is suddenly teleported to the
past dimension at first he has
absolutely no clue where he is or how he
got there but within a couple seconds
he's approached by a sulky looking aaron
who reveals that his story is the one
that did this with that said that's
basically everything you need to know
from the first four parts so before we
dive into part five i wanted to give a
shout out to youtubes for sponsoring
today's video youtubes make these
amazing collectible figures for pretty
much any series you can think of and
recently they sent me a couple of
designs from their attack on titan range
if you head on over to their website
you'll see there are a ton of other
characters as well and for me personally
the ones i'm probably going to get next
are the colossal titan attacking the
walls and also maybe the attack titan of
course they also have literally hundreds
of other limited edition collectibles
ranging from memes to games and to other
popular series like stranger things if
you're interested in getting one for
yourself or as a gift for someone else
then be sure to check out the link in
the description and thanks again to
youtubes for sponsoring the channel
okay so part five starts off back in
shiganshina directly after hitch was
killed by magat's anti-titan cannon as
we know louise and his story were nearby
watching the whole thing and with the
female titan being dead aaron being
paralyzed and even nowhere to be seen
these two couldn't afford to keep
standing around doing nothing in the
current moment there were still hundreds
of titans rampaging through the district
creating a genuine risk that the founder
might be eaten if even one of them
manages to slip past the scouts for the
sake of the island's future historia
would realize that if eren dies then so
does everyone else and it's why in a
moment of desperation she'd explained to
louise her last ditch solution to save
him meanwhile on the outside the global
alliance would be closely observing the
situation as the survey corps struggled
to deal with a huge amount of pure
titans assuming this continues then it's
only a matter of time until the alliance
can steal the founder so for now all
mageth has to do is just keep aiming at
the attack titan's brain however around
10 minutes later willie would start to
get suspicious as down on the ground a
worn-out looking astoria would slowly be
stumbling through the streets of
shiganjina directly above her mikusa
would be slashing any nearby pure titans
almost like she was clearing a path for
them to reach eren from willy's
perspective a move like this wouldn't
make any sense since he received intel
confirming that historia is just a
normal person who aaron would have never
allowed to inherit any titan abilities
that intel was reliable as it came from
the same spy who gave them ze's location
but despite everything willie could see
those unmistakable titan marks under her
eyes based on this he'd instantly tell
magath to shoot to stop her making
contact with eren and although the
command would want to do it there's a
good reason why he'd hesitate of all
people mcgath is clever enough to
realize that if he kills her now then
there'll be no more people of royal
blood left on the planet and if that
happens then the founding title can
never be activated again this is a big
problem for him since formally to
reclaim their place in the world they
need access to this power which is why
they secretly had plans to capture
historia after they captured the founder
itself killing her now would also kill
marley's one hope of regaining the
dominance they used to have and this
brief hesitation is what gave connie
time to catch mcgath by surprise as the
commander's body evaporates after being
hit with a thunderspear back on ground
level an exhausted historia lifts her
finger towards aaron's titan foot this
faint contact between the founder and a
titan of royal blood immediately
teleports them both into the past
dimension where they manifest in front
of the coordinate initially aaron would
be the most confused about where they
are because although he's obviously
heard about paz he's never seen this
landscape for himself by contrast
history is the one who does already know
this place given that five years ago she
saw visions of the coordinate through
ymir's memories after a short awkward
silence aaron would then turn to oscar
how they're able to get here to which
historia replies by explaining what
happened in shigajina with the survival
of the entire island on the line luis
made the ultimate sacrifice by passing
down the draw titan to summon of royal
blood before historia can even finish
the story though aaron interrupts her to
ask her why she would do this since in
his opinion mikasa and the scouts could
have handled the pure titans from his
point of view this was a pointless
sacrifice of louise's life and more
importantly historious life because from
this point forward she only has 13 years
left to live as he continues to lash out
suddenly a young girl emerges from the
coordinate itself forcing them to
temporarily switch their attention
although historia wouldn't have any clue
who this mystery girl is for some reason
her memories would flash back to the
time when friday was teaching her how to
read back then we saw how one of her
favorite book characters was a girl
called krista and in the present day she
get the feeling that somehow this girl
is connected to that particular memory
soon afterwards the girl in question
would then kneel down to aaron and
historia causing a surprised aaron to
respond by asking who she is as he then
kneels down to put his hand on her
shoulder something pretty interesting
would happen as all of the founders
memories abruptly begin flowing into his
head for that split moment in time the
two of them would gain an almost
complete understanding of each other
with aaron experiencing her pain and
acknowledging her desire to be freed
from two thousand years of slavery
slowly getting back to his feet he'd
explained to historia that this girl is
the original founding titan emir and due
to her obedience to the royal bloodline
history is the only one who can use her
full potential a revelation like that
would be totally unexpected but after
taking a minute to process his story
would wonder what yamir can actually do
it's likely that one of the first things
she'd ask is whether commander irving
can be summoned to this dimension partly
could she want his guidance on what to
do next but also could she want to know
what happened with the mission to save
zeke this request from historia is how
ervin ends up manifesting out of the
blue and it wouldn't take long for them
all to fill each other in on what's been
happening during the conversation the
commander would learn all about the
chaos in shiganshina including the
deaths of hitch and louise while aaron
and his story would learn about his
situation in the real world with irvin
literally about to die as soon as he
leaves his dimension he'd make it clear
that before that happens they need to
think of a plan to save the eldian
people this leads to an intense
discussion about their strategy going
forward with the characters having
different perspectives on how to use the
founder's power in aaron's case he'd
propose that now's finally the time to
do a full scale rumbling but they can
unleash the wall titans to trample all
life outside the island a global
massacre on this scale were guaranteed
that future generations would be able to
live in peace and it would also mean
that they no longer rely on titan powers
for their survival aaron would argue
that the outside world has taken the
lives of so many people they care about
including armin jean hanji and countless
others and so the only way to stop this
cycle of death is to put an end to
everything immediately though ervin
would disagree partly because of
full-scale rumbling would mean wiping
out their allies over the past five
years that azmobita would have held the
island in a ton of different ways and if
it wasn't for their resources the scouts
never would have been able to beat them
aliens on top of that elder has an
existing peace agreement with one of the
smaller middle eastern nations with the
commander believing that larger
countries in the region might be
convinced to do the same to him the idea
of destroying their potential allies
with the rumbling would be a pointless
waste of human life and instead he
proposed that they'd do a partial
rumbling to crush the global alliance
once that's done the entire world will
know the power of the founder is real
and from there lda can use diplomacy to
establish themselves on the world stage
on this issue historia would also fully
agree with the commander's approach
since if successful it would save the
island and give them a voice in the
international community however aaron
would aggressively reply by claiming
that everyone's plan could never work
because their supposed allies have
already betrayed them back in
shiganshina he noticed how the
anti-titan cannons used by magath were
exactly like the ones produced by the
middle east and when it comes to zeke
his secret location was discovered by
the global alliance even though the
azmobita were the only ones outside the
island who knew in aaron's mind this
would be proof that no one outside the
walls has any loyalty to elder and their
allies won't hesitate to betray them if
it serves their own best interests a
worldwide rumbling would therefore solve
this problem by creating a future where
none of their enemies exist and in this
moment he turned to historia to ask her
why she doesn't understand the queen
would respond by telling him that she
wouldn't be able to live with herself if
she killed billions of innocent people
and just as she says those words the
surrounding environment would begin to
change
thanks to emir's power historian would
transport the three of them into her own
memories where she'd reveal that since
arriving in paris her head keeps
flashing back to the time she spent with
her older sister as we already know
frida was objectively the kindest member
of the royal family and was the only one
who took the time to visit historia
during her terrible childhood years
afterwards when historia herself then
became the queen she tried to emulate
her sister by opening an orphanage and
spending time with kids who had no other
family in that sense it was frida who
showed her how to be the person she is
today and historia would believe that if
frida was in her current situation
there's no way she'd ever agree to
eren's plan following that comment
there'd be an awkward moment of silence
where he just quietly stands there
thinking before suddenly the environment
abruptly morphs into the rice chapel
this rapid change would catch both irvin
and historia completely by surprise but
for aaron he'd just start talking again
as if nothing happened out of nowhere
he'd admit to them that five years ago
at the meadow ceremony he saw a vision
of the future through his dad's memories
that future vision was unlocked
specifically because he touched historia
and now in the present day his story is
the one that's brought him back to pause
to relive the whole moment again as the
three of them observe from a distance
they witness grisha arriving to confront
the royals while frieda's conflicted
mind gets taken over by the will of carl
fritz seeing this takeover happen aaron
would claim that if frida had never been
brainwashed by the king then she would
have done anything to save her siblings
even if that meant activating the
rumbling he'd argue that although
historia might not want to believe it
the real freedom was determined to save
humanity by eliminating the titans so if
she knew that their true enemy was
humanity instead then odds are should
want to eliminate them as well
seconds later as grisha falls to his
knees in hesitation aaron would
forcefully tell him to stand up and
thanks to the attack titan's future
memory inheritance grishard in the past
would actually receive the message in
this way aaron is able to motivate his
dad to wipe out the rice bloodline while
the helpless historia can only watch on
as her family and massacre right in
front of her when the carnage finally
comes to an end aaron would begin to
explain that from the time he made
contact with yamir he understood the
founder on a personal level this
understanding made him realize that to
free emir from this prison and to save
the eldian people the rumbling is the
only option left for them to take as he
continues he go on to confess the
historian never really had control over
the founder since the vow to announce
war applies on some level to any person
of royal blood in the main series zeke
confirmed this when he said it took him
a mind-numbing amount of time to
override the vow and make emir obey him
and in this timeline historia simply
never had the chance to do that
consequently erin chose to let her
believe that she was in control because
he wanted to test if having the founders
power would give her the same
realization that he had despite his best
efforts though neither she or irvin was
convinced by his plan forcing him to go
ahead with this by himself as the three
of them then materialized back in parts
aaron would begin walking towards the
coordinate while urban and historia
would be chained up by yamir unable to
move historia would scream at aaron not
to go through with this since ending all
life outside the walls isn't exactly the
only solution to aldia's problems
meanwhile evan would try to break free
from the chains around his wrist but in
this case his conviction wouldn't be
strong enough for him to actually escape
although he'd agree with historia that a
full-scale rumbling is wrong he'd also
realize that stopping aaron at this
point would put the whole island a risk
being commander of the scouts he
wouldn't want his final action to be one
that potentially dooms the aldian race
and for that reason he'd stay in chains
as aaron keeps walking towards the paths
instantaneously a giant lightning bolt
would then strike the attack titan in
the real world while across elder the
three walls would start to crumble all
over the country unsuspecting civilians
would be crushed by the falling debris
as the millions of colossus titans
emerged for the first time in over a
century at the same time the rampaging
pure titans in shiganshina would be
struck by lightning as well and when the
smoke finally clears every last one of
them would have reverted back into human
form remember these people were just
innocent aliens who were blindfolded and
brought here by the global alliance as
so most of them wouldn't have any idea
about where they are to save their lives
and the lives of his fellow scouts aaron
used the founder's power to undo every
transformation in the world except for
himself and his army of titans this
single action is what turned them back
into humans and in a nearby forest it
also had some pretty big consequences
with ervin back in the real world and
literally about to be eaten the cart
titan would get hit with a bright flash
that engulfed her entire body this
lightning would be so powerful that the
blowback knocks the scouts off their
horses and in the chaos it'd definitely
take a few minutes for them to
understand what just happened just like
in chigachina there'd be thick smoke
covering the whole area but as irving
cautiously begins to walk through the
cloud he'd be stunned to find peak's
broken body on the ground
with that said that is the end of part
five of what if evan got the colossal
titan and if you want the series to
continue then be sure to drop a like and
subscribe to the channel if you haven't
already until the next one peace out